[Music]
one of my recent YouTube videos I made a
joke about incest and someone's comments
incest seems to be like a big theme with
you is everything okay I'm like with me
just look at any meme dude yeah princess
was like the [ __ ] yeah oh yeah that was
all PornHub was step bro
that was mass and I'm like with the
[ __ ] weird DM series The amount of
incest stories I get I'm like ah dude
really yeah man oh yeah I can't believe
I've never talked to you about this that
[ __ ] that email is a [ __ ] Honeypot of
bad [ __ ] I I assume half of it's fake
but even if 10 of it's real some of
those stories are just
way too much yeah and though that I
almost think they're real because
they're so specific yes it's crazy huh
you know I'm not gonna lie I just you
read the stories and you're like
wait no yeah you have to like back up
and go no this is two cousins this is
not cool yeah yeah so yeah yeah it's a
lot yeah so I was just like I was like
almost mad I'm like it's not me dude
yeah plenty of incest out there yeah my
brain is broken from knowing this [ __ ]
but this is a lot out there yeah yeah
that's true it's not just me yeah anyway
how's YouTube been for you lately
um
it's good honestly like I really like
starting a channel from scratch and now
like I've been posting on this new
channel for like six seven weeks maybe
and
it like it's just none of the [ __ ]
of like I wonder what people want to see
and whatever it's just one Focus yeah
okay put one video out a week and it's
the same every week yeah and you figure
out what people like and you kind of
evolve on that it just reminds me of
when you know I started in the beginning
yeah I was like okay what videos do
people like trying to figure that out
and it just there's none of this like oh
I'm trying new things and people are
don't like it and whatever it's like
it's none of that [ __ ] yeah it's just
like people that start watching the
beginning like this style so just keep
doing this style and eventually it'll
get more complicated down the line but
oh I really like starting [ __ ] from
scratch I realize like I just I'm
getting something off the ground is just
so and then finally like Finding
Traction is so exciting yeah to me so
that's like doing this new channel has
been really
just exciting and cool and also like
just posting more on my second Channel
and not really caring about
again about like how good the video is
or whatever it's just more about like
putting [ __ ] out regularly yeah is is a
nice thing too because it's like that's
kind of how content is now yep there are
I mean obviously like you know this is
kind of the reason why I want to keep my
main channel for more like curated
more thought out ideas but it seems like
just generally now it's like the people
that post
all the time are the people that you
just see all the time yeah you know no
one's talking about how good Ludwig or
Charlie's last video was it's just like
he puts out three a day and then yeah
there's gonna be good ones along the way
there's gonna be less good ones along
the way yeah that seems to be like the
more
the model now that I don't know like is
a little like gentler on your mental
health and stuff like that you know yeah
not that I'm like complaining but I'm
just saying like I worry so much about
and then and then you just don't make
anything because you're like too worried
you know about like oh it's gonna be
received and so on and so forth so
I've just been like trying to do [ __ ]
that I like and the money has definitely
gone down but again I've as long as I'm
like focusing on spending less then
you know my lifestyle's not scaling up
too much like that's not really that
crazy of a concern yeah at this point no
I mean I agree with a lot of that I
think um
kind of a similar thing I think
I had to
for my own brain in the same way I'm
like I gotta get over being precious
yeah yeah
but even with you it seems like you
found that format you have you in your
living room yeah and now you're just
putting [ __ ] out regularly in that
format yeah and as long as you're like
hitting that Cadence
then you can kind of rest easy a little
bit right it's that but it's also I
think all right this is gonna be a weird
ass and I know it's gonna seem like a
forced concept but just hear me out so
I essentially like I was talking with
Spock about this and
there's like this concept of like
managerial capitalism and the premise is
like
if you for example if you run a cookie
store it's different than when you scale
a cookie store and then you hire a
manager to run the cookie store it's
like obviously the manager is going to
be performance driven so
it's like at a point it's sometimes
impossible for like a company or a
corporation to be that invested in what
it's doing because it's it's driven by
managers it's not driven by the person
who made it which is whatever and I
think in a weird way we like we have
kind of experienced a similar thing
where we started our YouTube channels as
like I want to make this and then like
with the data and everything that we've
built around it we become managers of
ourselves and we're just we're only
thinking about the performance when and
then it becomes too scary to go back to
like well I just want to make something
yeah you know and like like you said
your mental health gets all [ __ ] up
from it because you're like
dude this started as something that was
really genuine now I'm why am I at the
mercy of all these weird factors I can't
even do the thing that like got me to
this point because it's all this weird
performance [ __ ] that you know it
was never part of my creative in the
beginning so I think
I think it's like a I think it's a good
thing that like you're just like [ __ ] it
I'm gonna go do a channel I don't care
about what the money is I don't care
about any of that [ __ ] because I think
that's how you stay
like successful is when you're willing
to burn it all down and then start over
yeah yeah which is hard because there is
that part of my brain that's like well
you've built this up over five years
yeah why would you waste that
opportunity there is this main Channel
sitting there with almost six million
subscribers yeah why wouldn't you post
as much as you can on that channel and
make as much money as you can now it's
because it's like well it doesn't that's
not really going to make me happy no
like building something from scratch is
what is what I find really fulfills me
especially if it's something I actually
enjoy which right now like the training
Vlogs I do you know that's like I'm
already doing something I really really
like to document it isn't that crazy of
a step and it actually makes it more
enjoyable right now yeah is thinking
about how I can make my training like
creative and thinking how I can show it
creatively I think you're bringing up a
good point which is what actually makes
you happy I think that's
or or you know happiness is it may be a
tough thing to achieve but like
what makes you feel I guess accomplished
and like what is it that makes you feel
like you want to keep going like I think
that's the important thing to angle on
and
um
I I don't know I I guess in a similar
way yeah like [ __ ] around in my
living room and and just trying
different [ __ ] like I think I've had
more fun definitely
in in the same way of like trying to
start over and start something new and
and
you know I think there's a point where
people recognize that you're doing it
for money and then becomes weird between
you and the people watching what you're
doing yeah yeah it's like okay well why
why are any of us here yeah just for you
to get paid that's [ __ ] strange yeah
so no I think that I think that's great
I also think with the Cody trains
Channel I think it's
like super healthy that you're kind of
going like Lo-Fi about it yeah because I
think that's the other Temptation it's
like oh well I was successful over here
so I'm going to take all this knowledge
in terms of like production value yeah
I'm gonna apply it here and it's gonna
be like the coolest biggest thing and
it's like it doesn't have to be that
yeah yeah it's it's more it's more
captivating if it's like oh damn this is
just like Cody just straight up pulling
out his phone yeah that's crazy yeah you
know that that feels more like real and
special yeah versus like you know
[ __ ] hiring a guy to like shoot you
and you're getting like Doc style edits
and you're like today was a hard day
training yeah which is not me like I'm
not like I can't you know do that type
of [ __ ] for me it was just like the
easiest way to do it was Lo-Fi but it
was also like this is probably the most
genuine way to do it because I really do
wish want to show like that this [ __ ]
sucks sometimes sometimes it's [ __ ]
awesome but it's like everything in one
but you know what's cool is that like
I'm sure you're getting this too is like
people that now
are recognizing the dynamic that you
have
with you know with Alex and with cash
and they're probably commenting on it
and stuff like that I like seeing that
like you know like
things that signify that people are
actually watching watching but also like
into it yes like
like I [ __ ] we uh our flight landed
on Thursday and we're Walk we're
de-boarding
and with this stupid joke on the channel
because it's called Cody trains choo
choo that's like one of those stupid
jokes right I say it sometimes in the
video
and we're walking and this guy like
looks at me is like oh my God and takes
out his airpod and in my head I'm like
he's gonna say something about that's
cringe or whatever and he goes Cody and
I look back and he goes choo choo
like yes
and I walk away and I was like Kelsey
and I were like laughing and I was like
so thrilled because I was like that's so
[ __ ] cool choo choo that is a new
thing that I'm building that I'm I'm
risking you know it's not a crazy risk
but like it's still it's like I'm
putting everything the I have into this
new thing and for someone to like
recognize it and show me that they like
it in person was like wow that was a
huge step yeah or a huge you know
whatever signifier then oh it's a good
feeling yeah it is so it was it's cool
yeah I'm uh
I think I don't think like I'm pretty
sure I'm probably gonna start a car
Channel next year nice but what I really
want to do is uh
uh I'm gonna like kind of rebuild my
garage a little bit and I wanna you
cannot stop doing construction
I am but this actually won't be that bad
um I just have to like insulate two
walls and then just like do some epoxy
but
is exactly what he said a year ago I'm
at the gym no no that that was ambitious
now I have a more realistic idea of like
what [ __ ] takes like I'm literally just
hanging up like 200 shop lights and then
just because the walls are
they it's like old pegboard and they're
not insulated so there's like straight
up like holes into the outside oh okay
like I can see through it oh okay so I
just need to insulate the two walls but
I want to do it and then I want to build
[ __ ] in there yes like build a car yeah
or um yeah so I think like that's the
kind of the direction I want to go with
the channel